JD as you know has a personal
relationship with Samantha bee yes JD
quickly again how did you become friends
with Samantha bee I know was on Twitter
but what happened you direct messaged
her fight over a direct message each
other and that was basically basically
are the most of our relationship so
Samantha bee was up here doing some
stuff for us the other day I think she
was on the wrap-up show or something
they had a conversation we were lucky
enough to tape it oh and it's every bit
as awkward as you think it would be what
do you do you freeze up when you have to
talk in person to people yeah especially
when there's a microphone in front of me
yeah
he's blaming the mic I wish we could
hide it and see I know I've been in
conversations in it's no different it is
no different
here's the awkward conversation between
JD and Samantha bee yeah I think that we
can have a normal conversation
I'll make this oh god I know I should
bring this up okay you know I mean we're
13 seconds and I know what the [ __ ] he's
mumbling about yeah
you hear anything like that Fred I'll
warn you JD JD does a lot of grunting in
this conversation really yeah now
started again I didn't mean to interrupt
hi it's really nice to see you yeah I
think we can have a normal conversation
I got interrupt again why wouldn't you
say JD like she goes hey JD it's really
nice to see you and you go oh yeah
like why wouldn't you say oh so nice to
see you too Samantha for whatever reason
my brain locks up whatever and I can't
actually say I just don't know what to
say at certain times I can't physically
say it but I mean like in other words
she goes hey nice to see you you don't
think to say nice to see you too now
what do you think you just go oh you
know like sometimes like in the morning
so if you will say good morning to me or
whatever
me I literally say good morning back cuz
you forget that that's the appropriate
response just for whatever reason I feel
weird saying it I don't know
ah nice - peanut butter you but all you
have to do is literally repeat what she
said I can't why I'll practice with you
watch this
good morning JD how are you done good
morning how are you sometimes I'm good
at it most times I'm not how about good
morning Howard could you say that
good morning our yeah but it's Samantha
Bay so you screwed up already you think
good morning Howard is Samantha B but
the rule is JD just repeat what this
person says to you I guess I feel weird
repeating back that you know of for
whatever reason repeating back common
thing to return a greeting I'm not a
common person I don't know what to tell
you here we go he says his brain locks
up turns into folio fur it's really nice
to see you yeah I think that we can have
a normal conversation
I'll make this God I know I should bring
this up okay you know on the way oh my
gosh what is going on the way to go to
your show okay I ended up seeing like a
dead body
I'm sidewalk like someone had just
jumped off a building building what are
you laughing about
JD what are you laughing about
[Music]
first I mean you saw a dead body on the
street and you didn't come on this show
and tell us I it's something I haven't
really thought much about since I
probably blocked it out you didn't ask
me how my day was I just don't know why
you're laughing about it if it is
representing you it's like a complete
opposite reaction
I was really weird like I had to go here
shows like I saw other people contacting
police and so much you can do yes
the guy was were you shaken was it
horrible oh yeah
I can't like I can't like I've never
walked up to a cat actually that's not
true I walked up to my grandmother's
casket but I can't do that is that yeah
so uh how's your day so far 100% the
highlight interesting all right what are
you doing after this are you doing later
today what's back to my office then I'm
actually gonna go do Colbert tonight oh
so I'm doing like it's a real busy day
what are you gonna do after this uh
today is laundry day so I have to do my
laundry laundry I gotta go now thank you
very much really I had to duck out so
fast I had to go look for car wrecks and
laugh at people Hey I can't sit there
all day wow I was abrupt but he asked
like three questions in a row like do
you have to ask all your questions at
once oh did he do then what are you
doing after this what are you doing
later this evening what are you doing
today what are you doing in 1900 this
Tony are you doing three years ago at
this exact time we like in high school
what are you doing John June 19th from
there do you have actual feelings JB oh
yeah yeah of course I D I think I can I
get that most all the time so how did
you feel seeing Samantha be it was very
nice the fear that would have been this
thing to say but yeah okay
[Music]
there yeah I'm toasting mr. quarterback
JD how did you get past the body oh I
had to walk past to go down the block so
I just sort of
stared straight ahead you know after I
saw people were dealing with the
situation I don't want to make you feel
bad but you're like a mumbly Angel of
Death